Saudi Arabia doesn't give a fly about  making money on any of these other  endeavors this is all marketing come to  Saudi Arabia we're gonna run out of oil  eventually we need to prove to you that  there's it here besides oil Derricks and  Mecca I didn't even know Saudi Arabia  yeah you know the Ronaldo fans are  watching Saudi football fans maybe they  want to go to Saudi to watch a football  fan now there's an excuse not his excuse  to travel a little bit right like and  people will go do that [ __ ] if Michael  Jordan was playing in another country  you don't think that Michael Jordan fans  would go there and watch a game 100 so  will they make back the 275 million  dollars like dollar per dollar I don't  know but it is an infinite amount of  money that is returned from viewing  Saudi Arabia as more than just those two  things yeah right